hello everybody well it's been a big
saga with the whole patreon situation a
lot of people have been following this
this problem since patreon banned sargon
of akkad there's been a lot of waves sam
harris deleted his patreon Sam Harris
Jordan Peterson Dave Rubin I've also
seen quite a bit of people who wanted to
boycott patreon and leave the platform
at the beginning I was like okay I'm
gonna delete my patreon I'm going to to
protest this I set up the SUBSCRIBE star
some people went to subscribe sorry that
he got blocked now it seems subscribe
star is working again let's see if we
can can see it and so the SUBSCRIBE star
it seems that it's working again those
that want to support me through that
channel can um all you need to do though
if you've already if you're already on
subscribe sorry and you've already
follow me there you need to go back into
your account and you need to re-enter
your information because I don't know
exactly what they did what they had to
change their systems and so they need
people to re-enter their information so
that you can continue to give on that
platform but of course what I would
prefer just in terms of being safe with
what we're doing is for people to go
onto my website you can go to the
symbolic world.com slash support and on
there you will find you know all the
different tiers that were on patreon and
people can follow me there you'll get
notifications for QA you'll get
notifications for also you know advanced
questions and all the advanced videos
all that just like people had on patreon
and subscribe star um Matthew Ramar of
anomalous design has worked really hard
for the past few weeks to try to get
this all set up so that we have all the
notifications and everything so great
thanks to him he's been doing some great
job for content providers
I really suggest you check it out I'll
put the link into the description he's
been creating a system to protect
content for people who are making it and
are either afraid
of of being banned from different
platforms or you know are seeing this
escalate and know that it's going to get
worse and worse so he has a system
called content is safe and for a monthly
fee he will upload your content
automatically on to bid shoot and D Tube
and other protected sources where
because it's using torrent technology
then it's not the the content isn't
actually anywhere it's being shared by
different users which means that um it's
a lot safer from being censored and so
that's some great stuff so I would
really encourage people to go to to my
to my website if you want to support me
there I've been thinking a lot about the
whole patreon situation and at first I
wanted to just delete my patreon and
after the story kind of cooled down and
I looked and I've examined what is
happening it seems like what's going on
is a lot bigger than patreon this deep
platforming we've heard the big names
but there's a lot of small people being
deep platformed on Twitter on YouTube on
different platforms we saw for those who
followed the story the CEO out of Apple
Tim Cook made a speech where he
basically said using very strange
Genesis symbolism which was almost is a
sign of the times talking about the
knowledge of good and evil and how we
need to act and so the tech companies
need to stop these dangerous people who
are spreading hate and everything and of
course everybody no one likes hate but
obviously we all know that by now the
word hate speech has become a a just a
signifier for anything that they
disagree with and so because of that it
seems like the pressure that was on
patreon is not coming from patreon it's
coming from much higher up it's coming
from the credit card companies and
there's some shady stuff going on if you
go to the patreon website and you look
not patreon but there's a website called
Graf Graf Treon and that website shows
patreon stats and creator stats and
everything and if you go on that website
there's some very strange
things happening at patreon here right
here you have the patreon creators and
the donations per month so if you look
at the dates January 15 we have 12
million monthly payouts and 5000 pledges
on the 16th which is right after Jordan
Peterson Dave Rubin and probably a whole
lot of people deleting their patreon
account it drops a million dollars and
then the next day it goes way back up
all even higher than what it was today
before and that is some shady stuff and
so there's some things that are either
they're they're they're pretending or
they've got some support from the big
banks or from the credit cards there's
something else going on which is bigger
than just patreon and so because the D
platforming on patreon obviously is more
visible because it's affecting people's
revenue directly but so is the
monetization on YouTube so is the
banning of people from YouTube as well
and so I don't think that at least for
now just leaving these platforms is
going to it's going to do anything
because it's it's a lot bigger than
patreon for now what I'm hoping to do is
I want to direct all of you guys towards
this this new so supporting me directly
on my website but there again you're
going to be using PayPal you're gonna be
using credit cards the problem is a lot
bigger and it's actually quite
frightening how what this is pointing to
this kind of system of control and if
this system of financial control becomes
ideologically possessed we are looking
at a a very scary you know
revelations mark of the beast' situation
here I'd probably be doing a video on
that very soon I hope but in the
meantime we're gonna do what we can
through using these platforms that are
not perfect and are obviously let's say
seem to be giving in to the enemy we're
going to have to keep using these
platforms if you want to follow me on
bit shoot on D tube you can go ahead and
find me there I'll put the links in the
description
if people do move towards those
platforms its it would be great for for
this situation but to be honest I don't
think it's going to happen just because
of the strength that YouTube has and the
and the clout that it has in terms of
how is able to give information away so
this is a bit of a sad video in terms of
my how I see the situation hopefully
join Peterson's platform will will be
better who knows if he's going to be
able to get it done because it's also
part the banks are part of this and so
it's not just a question of of will it's
also a question of of the system which
seems to it seems to be appearing now
that let's say the underbelly of the
system seems to be appearing more and
more and so that's all I have to say for
today as usual guys I really appreciate
all your support and we're gonna keep
plowing on in 2019 I've got a video
coming out on the ring from the Lord of
the Rings and then from then on I'm just
gonna keep going with you guys and see
how far we can go with this so thanks a
lot and see you soon